what's up you guys it's graham here so
welcome to my first ever podcast
ever that that i've been i don't want to
say i'm hosting it i mean you're mostly
hosting me
but right right co-host and co-host
there's no host okay i don't like that
intro should i redo it
it's a podcast it's fine podcasters are
wrong
businesses when you were younger when
you were younger there were any
businesses that you started up or you
you tried to start up now looking in you
know hindsight they actually weren't
i wanted to come up with a free cell
phone plan where
instead of you know when you call a
phone it's like it rings like
[Music]
yeah yeah imagine if you get a free cell
phone so you wouldn't have to pay any
sort of like
monthly data or like anything like that
so you don't have to pay like 30 40
bucks a month but instead
anytime you make an outgoing call you'll
hear an
ad for like 10-15 seconds
and then the call goes through whoa
that's so
i figured you know like or or when
people call
you let's just say instead of hearing
the
you know it's ringing or you know how
people have a ring back tone where it
plays some classical music or something
imagine if a person calls you and they
just hear an ad
until you pick up the phone it's just a
free cell phone plan
where you can make as many calls as you
want within the united states
but it's just you listen to an ad before
the call goes through
not a bad idea so i yeah i came up i
know i got a business plan in there
but basically i was one of those kids
where it's like okay so there's 300
million people in the united states
if we can get one percent of those
people
and we make an average of you know 15
cents a day
you know you know all of this and yeah
yeah
based on that that was my that was my
pitch was just
was just that like this amount of people
make this amount right right uh i
started looking into it
and it was just it was i felt so over my
head i just like i had this idea it's
hard
but i was like where do i start how do i
get advertisers i think i was like 18
years old i was like what do i do
never pursued it have you ever heard of
brewster's millions so it's about a guy
who was like a failed minor league
pitcher
so nothing spectacular and uh he just
finds out like out of nowhere that his
uncle had
like a ton of money basically and the
thing was there was like it was like a
game
he said if you can spend 30 million
dollars and have net assets zero by the
end of it then you get the rest
like the other 300 million so this guy
in this movie he had a month to spend 30
million dollars
and if he couldn't spend it he didn't
get the extra 300 million
what would you do would you how would
you spend like that 30 million dollars
easy i would say art cars
watches real estates i mean but then
you'd have assets
oh you have to spend oh and not have any
assets yeah
you would be able to rent a really
expensive house there are plenty of
houses that you could rent uh hamptons
hampton's prime season i think it's like
200 000 a month uh you could pay
even more uh for like full staff and
stuff like that you could rent a whole
bunch of houses like that
you're not owning any assets on that you
could rent some really expensive
it's basically renting everything you
could almost buy like
really expensive price uh priceless
paintings and then
damage assign as oh do you damage them
and they're
so much less like imagine buying let's
say like a mona lisa let's just
people would be so mad at you and you
just you just you just
light it on fire you land on fire
something like that and then the ashes
you sell the ashes back for let's say
you know a million dollars or something
like that
and then now you only have a million to
spend in 30 days you know you could do
that with with exotic cars too you just
get like a vintage ferrari
you know 10 million dollars just crash
it crash it and then sell it
a mill right and it's got to be with
something like that and then just
you know now you spend a million dollars
or something just repeat that it's a lot
of work i would probably
i'd probably take the challenge but i'd
find a way to spend it speaking of rings
let's see now what is this to the camera
oh this is oh wow what you got this
beefed up didn't you this is not it
yeah wow
don't tell jack is it cool if jack holds
it
yes okay wait wait let me let me feel it
first let me loot
jack's going to break i just want i want
to find jack's reaction
that way that's i thought that was fake
the whole time
is that a diamond so so jeff hold it
okay wait wait we gotta get your
reaction on this okay because i know
wait guys oh you know what
we might just have to get some b-roll
yeah
i think you saw it when it was just the
like diamond
okay um uh do you want to be in this as
well i
i think i want i want both of your
reactions
because you you don't i don't i don't
think you know either
what no what it just
hold it guess how much you think that is
how much
i know how much the engagement ring is
oh wait guess how much that would be
so the cufflinks that your husband wore
during the wedding
were like fifty thousand right
fifty-five and they had diamonds on them
right yeah mm-hmm
one and a half you're gonna guess that
one and a million
yep it's like this or a lamborghini
right so like okay
i think this could be like a hundred and
fifty
hundred seventy five thousand dollars
okay you wanna tell them that's how much
this ring was
actually but this ring is definitely
over a million dollars
look at this look at his face i can't
hold it
like
[Laughter]
[Music]
every day the only reason i'm wearing
this is because i have an interview
after okay yeah
but i i never wear this this is like
locked up in a safety deposit box
yeah i know wow i just wanted jack's
reaction to that that's all
your reactions are the best track is the
vision even pulling up to the house is
whoa
we got monetized too
that means that you guys can watch ads
in this video exactly how exciting is
that so
we should share how much we've made so
far okay so we've made 72.72
wow and that's a few days uh now 72 but
but you have to consider how much work
went into that
i would say from actually filming the
episodes i would say 20 minutes of prep
work
an hour of filming uh christine's one
took
that was an entire night from like 8 p.m
to midnight yeah
of doing that plus editing editing that
one
probably took me like five hours to edit
it's less yeah we'll probably make it
like five dollars an hour for
we're doing this right now realistically
so that's that's why you got to get your
two
free stocks from weeble that's why you
have to click on the ads watch them all
the way through
we can't tell them do that but why
you're not supposed to tell people to
watch the ads and watch them all the way
through okay
so don't do that no don't do that guys
is it too late to invest in tesla
oh that's a tough one you know i gotta
say if you're a long-term investor i
don't think it's too late
because i you know i personally believe
it's gonna be a two three thousand
dollar stock in the future if i you know
over the next five years or so
but at the same time if you're if you're
trying to do a short-term
move around it i just don't think it's
the right stock to do it around um it's
too volatile
it's almost like it's one of those
stocks that very few come along kind of
like an amazon
an apple a google where you just buy it
and you just
hold it man you just throw it in the
filing cabinet you try not to look at
the stock price it's good you know if
it's at 500 a year from now or 2
000 you try not to make judgments off
that it's one of those you just buy
and you forget about it don't you think
a lot of people think the same thing
that like tesla is going to be the next
you know
amazon or whatever and they're all
piling into it now with that expectation
don't you think that's maybe influence
the price range because yeah part of me
looks at the
company like it's maybe like four or 500
bucks yeah
but but you but it might never get there
because people just have so much faith
in the company that it's never going to
hit what it's
i think kind of valued at well you know
with these special opportunities they
really
just trade you know way ahead of
themselves like years in advance
amazon's done that since the beginning
of time you know since when that one
went public in the 90s
it's always traded way ahead of the
market because
a lot of investors just look at and
they're like it's just the future
and obviously it's now as well when it
comes to amazon and that's why that
one's at a 1.3
trillion dollar market cap right now
amazon because
if you're trying to base amazon off of
what they're doing today
there's no way a 1.3 trillion valuation
makes sense for amazon today
but when you base it off of what they're
doing in five years it might be a steal
so and that and that goes for a lot of
these great companies you know there was
there's been a lot of times where
apple's been way overvalued
and there's been times where it's been
undervalued uh so
you know sometimes these long-term
investments you have to throw it in the
filing cabinet
so i think i'm about 30 000
in credit card debt right now no yeah oh
wait no you're kidding geez don't do
that
that's funny no yeah like i don't belong
on this your channel
yeah where are you your audience is
gonna crucify you yeah i don't know
no i'm saying well we got a prankster
yeah i just spent a lot last year
remember remember where i used to live
yeah yeah so so i saw i saw andrew's
place
3700 bucks a month oh and i was like 37
for reference and i also went to russia
and japan
and paris okay yeah so i'm so i'm sorry
about like laughing i thought you were
kidding me i'm like oh yeah i know it's
no it's fine
i've done this like a couple times in my
life and i always get out of it
where is the debt being held on what
interest rate are you paying on that day
oh it's probably ridiculous i probably
have paid three or four grand in
interest alone this year
your best bet honestly is you got to
throw everything in the savings
everything
you mean take everything out of savings
whatever you have in savings
just barely enough because because
here's the thing my thinking is that in
an emergency you could always put more
money back in the credit cards
if you need to you could spend money on
credit cards get up the debt again
that's fine well i did get
unemployment and that's that that helped
a lot yeah so i paid off a bunch with
that
do you feel like you can't trust
yourself to use your credit card yeah
that's the thing i don't know
like my self-control and stuff you know
then don't get it correct then i agree
with you on that yeah
paid off close out the cards i would
keep one card open
yeah right do like 500 limits or
whatever a thousand dollar limit on the
grid
my dog just had surgery like two weeks
ago and there's seven hundred dollars
yes so many things happened you know
yeah i made my first ever
option trade gosh i told you not to do
it so he told me not to do it
in our private mentorship group link
down below in the description
um i was talking with the guys in the
zoom call and one of them
was telling me about selling puts so i
decided to do it and i sold a put on nio
strike price seven dollars
for those guys you know options that's
what i did and uh
yeah i made like 29 off a 700 investment
it was a small investment obviously i'm
not gonna do a bunch of money
in the beginning when i'm you know doing
options trading but i made some money
off of it congratulations and i remember
telling graham and graham was just like
oh my god
but i mean you would have made more
money just buying
two two shares of tesla you would have
made way more yeah but that would have
required like a two thousand dollar
investment and also
you invested two thousand dollars no
invested seven hundred
wow well you could buy fractional shares
you would have made more money buying a
fractional share in robin hood
anyways i made some money and graham was
just like oh my god
and you're just you win a couple of
times a little bit
and then one time you lose and that's it
i made like three four percent in what
five days i want you to do it 20 times
and i want you to make money 15 out of
those 20 times then i think that would
be a good
gauge of how well you're doing all right
75 of the time you make money i'm gonna
continue trading options and gambling
away
all the money i'm getting from the
podcast do you want to say the thing
that
where you like put that money in that
one stock and then made like
40 or eighty dollars yeah i'll say that
so one of them that that
like is a silly example but wire card
that bankrupt company for fun uh i put
two grand in wire card because i noticed
it was hovering just within you know set
range and i think well
you know if if i get time it was
literally bouncing like you had these
two
levels it would just balance between
them so i figured well i may as well
just try to buy towards the low and then
set you know a limit and so it
automatically sells when i reached a
certain point i made like 80 bucks on
that
but i had to invest two thousand like i
was prepared to make eighty dollars off
two thousand yeah but i was prepared to
lose that and that was within a few
hours
and the company was going bankrupt the
next day it went down to like
you know i think two days later it was
like 90 something cents and what'd you
buy that
uh i bought it at nine dollars and sixty
something and i sold it at nine dollars
and
ninety something it was funny because
you said like with taxes and everything
considered it was like forty dollars
that you already offered forty
two thousand dollar like investment we
went and got burritos
yeah paid for burritos that's what was a
goal it was a fun little thing for me to
do
for those of you who don't know me i am
formerly known
as graham's girlfriend or savannah
smiles but my name
is macy and i am on this podcast i live
with graham
and i am his live-in actress
roommates we're just roommates we're
keeping this pg
for parental guidance so welcome so you
were into finance
a lot even before you met graham yeah
yeah that was something that we really
clicked about i
remember one night that graham and i
first started talking i think we were up
till like 2 a.m
talking about credit card points and
different credit cards he was telling me
about like these ones because
my parents were always very against any
with like the annual
annual fees yeah i almost said
statements
i knew that was wrong but the annual
fees so then when he started saying hey
no
like this is how it pays for it back i
was like wow like my mind was just blown
so i can remember there's that we were
talking about chris he knew my credit
score before we even went on a first
date that's what made him so interested
in me did you ask that question right
away i think so
i don't know if you asked i was like
indirectly be like you know something
about credit scores and then it just
came up in conversation
i don't think i asked directly like
what's your credit yeah what's your
credit score
i think it just brought it up i think i
just offered this information willingly
i'm like by the way my credit card's
over 750 and he's like
what you're that age and your credit
score
is that high and like yeah yeah it's not
like the text like
guess what i'm wearing tonight yeah it's
like guess what my credit score is
7.50 and like oh i'll say no more graham
is gonna
review my budget so i prepared my income
and expenses
and i can throw up a screenshot of the
spreadsheet
and graham is gonna look at all my stuff
all right so here we go so we got video
editing four thousand i wanna read this
millennium line
four thousand one hundred and twenty
seven dollars and twenty nine cents we
got the mentorship group
eleven hundred and six dollars a month
hourly okay
six hundred dollars podcast 144 dollars
and 55 cents okay
decent income that's good that's good
but then we got your expenses uh
basil on mint with matthew what's that
okay so that was that
the the pho that i got the vietnamese
pho with my friend where you got the
spring rolls
uh what's lucky groceries
why is it lucky i don't know that was
what mint classified it as
i just got all this from men lucky
paypal don't know what that was
15. okay then we got little caesar's 539
okay that's right
two trees cafe eighteen dollars at a
cafe what was that
uh i got this thing called a monte
cristo it's just a sandwich
ah my friends wanted to go think okay
okay so ralph's 140 dollars that was
groceries of the month audible
fifteen dollars a month fees in charge
what's why you bank b's and charges i
have no idea what that was
back in the box 757 that's expensive for
jack-in-the-box
yeah groceries 26 habit thompson for
venmo a dollar arco gas okay groceries
so you went to groceries twice so you're
eating 220 a month on groceries
yeah okay let's find bonds
so gross 59 7809 total expenses 419
dollars
that's a lot net income 55. my expenses
are a lot yeah that's a lot of money
uh get rid of those fees and charges no
jack in the box
you want to get that down to like 380 a
month and i'd be happy i mean it's it's
good i i i mean obviously i have no
complaints on this
i mean overall it's not terrible
like i don't have very expensive taste
no for the most part
it's good this reminds me of my expenses
back in the day
where i would have like really nothing
yeah but uh yeah it's good
yeah i'm fortunate i don't have very
expensive taste
yeah you know i just don't need very
much to operate how many streams of
income
do you have if you're willing to
disclose this oh sure so
language have number one uh google
adsense number two
paid partnerships affiliate programs um
my youtube course investment income oh
investment income just edit that
oh instagram ads when people buy ads for
me on
instagram oh yeah that's from you wait
how does that work oh
like sponsored like sponsorships oh i'm
like wait instagram has ads
and what yeah sponsorships um
oh and i have my workbooks this is an
amazing
income source because you produce it's
like a books like a pdf
i call them handbooks and workbooks and
they sell for like seven dollars
and the one that i made was for english
language learners it has
180 pages and in the first month we made
25 000
selling it um wait what is it exactly
it's like you know it's a lot of things
in one handbook so we have like a
thousand words that every english
language learner should know
uh tv shows that you should watch like a
lot of information about the english
language yeah so you have like seven or
so
yeah quite a few yeah are you able to
disclose percentages or
numbers yeah sure i think uh google
adsense
this month is around seventeen thousand
for which for
all combined okay everything compared to
you yeah i watched it yesterday
oh wait which one the uh the net worth
oh wow yeah yeah yeah
a lot of people watch that video um
then so workbooks around 10k
every month uh paid partnerships uh
30k a month wow wait what what kind of
paid partnerships do you do
so like companies that will work with
like product placements in my videos
what companies audible skillshare
uh we got it we got to talk about this
afterwards because yeah i'm not doing
anywhere close to that wow maybe i'm
getting yeah
yeah so we got to do that sponsorships
um
yes some of them are on instagram but
youtube is a
bigger chunk um workbooks um
last month it was around 9k what else
well language of salary i don't want to
disclose it
what else do we have oh courses last
month i made
around 30k on courses
that's good that's really good i i was
adding it up in my head that's almost
100 000 a month
about yeah about wow so that's there's
your title right there
yeah okay so how do you say hit the like
button um
not like not like not like nash media
no like nice